la sixième extinction animal de masse
est bel et bien commencée c'est ce que
vient de confirmer une équipe de
scientifiques ont sur chantal ont soif
et les nouvelles assez inquiétante assez
inquiétante parce que nous avons besoin
de toute la biodiversité disponible pour
survivre pour vivre ce soit pour manger
pour nous soigner et je peux peut-être
rappelé d'entrée de jeu que la dernière
fois qu'on a eu une extinction de masse
était ya plus de 65 millions d'années
quand les dinosaures sont disparus donc
c'est pas rien ce type de phénomène bon
c'est pas la première fois qu'on parle
de la sixième extinction qu'est ce qui
nous fait croire que la maintenance et
bien bel et bien commencé pour
comprendre dont on parle faut peut-être
la remise en contexte il faut savoir que
dans l'histoire de l'évolution de la vie
sur terre c'est normal c'est naturel que
des espèces disparaissent on appelle ça
le tout naturel d'extinction des espèces
le problème pour les scientifiques c'est
de calculer ce taux là or ces
scientifiques qui viennent de publier
leurs résultats dans la revue savante
cents à 116 ont utilisé des faux cils
une banque de données ils ont été très
très très conservateur ils ont surestimé
ce taux naturel et ils ont calculé que
si on surestime vraiment qu'on vend ou
pire du pire on a pour chaque vie mille
espèces deux espèces qui disparaissent
chaque siècle
donc si ce que ça nous donne ils ont
vraiment très conservateur parce qu'ils
veulent que leur résultat disant qu' on
est vraiment dans la sixième période
d'extinction et un est pas qu il soit
crédible et donc là ils en viennent à la
conclusion que c'est bel et bien là
commençait déjà ces deux libyens
commencé et pour ce faire ils se fient à
des chiffres qui nous viennent des
espèces disparues selon l'union
internationale pour la conservation de
la nature
et quand on regarde on compare ces
données là haut tout naturel qu'ils ont
estimé les résultats des chiffres sont
vraiment très troublant alors je vous en
présente quelques uns
si on regarde selon les estimés des
scientifiques on aurait neuf espèces
disparues depuis 1900 or dans la réalité
on parle plutôt de regarder 477 espèce
disparue depuis les 900 c'est en faisant
beaucoup plus à fond
beaucoup plus important alors ça veut
dire ça par exemple qu'on a si on
transpose 69 espèces de mammifères 80
espèces d'oiseaux 24 espèces de reptiles
146 me suis bien
158 de poisson ça donne par exemple des
la tourte voyageuse de l'oiseau qui est
disparu également des phoques des lions
bref c'est vraiment une perte pour la
biodiversité
c'est tellement gros qu'on a un peu de
mal à imaginer ce que ça veut dire
vraiment mais ce qui est trop tard pour
agir
le message à retenir céline c'est qu'au
cours du dernier siècle on a vu des
espèces disparaître qui normalement en
vertu du tout naturelle aurait dû
prendre des milliers d'années à
disparaître alors la conclusion des
chercheurs c'est qu'on a à peu près
trois générations pour intervenir
ça veut dire préserver les habitats
protéger les espèces et sinon les
conséquences pourraient être très grave
pour l'humanité
on espère que le message va être entendu
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'on
l'entend snaj malheureusement merci
beaucoup joué